[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week and joining me
as an author journalist editor and free
speech advocate Fleming Rose welcome to
the Rubin report nice to be here I'm
glad to have you here because you are
sort of at the epicenter of everything
that our current free speech battle is
all about so I guess I'm gonna give you
an open easy question to start how did
you end up in the middle of this battle
well you know I I didn't choose this
fight it was imposed upon me 11 years
ago when I was the editor responsible
for the publication of the so-called
Danish Muhammad cartoons they didn't
come out of the blue some people
sometimes think they were published as a
response to an ongoing conversation in
Denmark and Western Europe about the
problem of social censorship when it
comes to treating Islam yeah and back
back then I think I was pondering two
questions
his self-censorship taking place when it
comes to Deen with Islam do we make a
difference between Islam and other
religions and ideologies question number
one and question number two if there is
self-censorship is that self-censorship
based in reality or is it just the
consequence of a sick imagination not
based in reality is the fear real or is
it fake
yeah so 11 years later I think we can
say for sure the answer to both
questions is yes yeah they're in
self-censorship and the self-censorship
is based in reality because people were
killed in Paris I live with bodyguards
24/7 when I'm back home in Denmark so so
it is a real problem yeah it's so
interesting to me that 11 years ago 2005
you were addressing the idea of
self-censorship because that's obviously
different than you know what we have
here with the First Amendment where the
government can't censor us because my
awakening over the last couple years
about this has been about the self
censorship part that we are doing it to
ourselves so just to back up to the
specifics of what happened you guys
solicited cartoons from people right yes
yes yeah it's it's it started with
children's book Danish right I was
writing a book about the life of the
Prophet Mohammed
in Denmark when you publish a children's
book you need illustrations of the main
character I suppose you do the same here
same here that goes across boy yeah and
it turned out that that the right eye
had difficulties finding an illustrator
who wanted to take on the job and he
went public saying you know I written
this book but I have had difficulties
finding an illustrator because of fear
yeah and the guy who finally took on the
job insisted on anonymity which is a
form of self-censorship you do what not
want to appear under your real name
because you are afraid of what might
happen to you to you and in fact this
illustrator later acknowledged that he
insisted on anonymity because he was
afraid then he made a reference to the
fate of two Bangkok dodj filmmaker was
killed in 2004 because of a documentary
he did that was critical of Islam yeah
who then many people know the note
except I add Hirsi Ali who I think is
one of the greatest people on planet
earth coming after her next exactly and
the second individual was Salman Rushdie
who is 1989 was the object of an fatwah
by Ayatollah Khomeini in Iran and had to
live in hiding for many years so so so
that was you know the context and some
people were saying oh this was just a
media stunt by this children's writer to
sell more books other people were saying
no there is no censorship and and you
you know through the commissioning of
those cartoons I wanted to put focus on
this issue
self-censorship taking place or is it
not and how to illustrators and
cartoonist in Denmark face this issue
and I received 12 cartoons that were
published September 30th 2005 and I
wrote a short text laying out the
rationale behind this journalistic
project I I don't think that it in any
way transgressed you know what we
usually do as an editors and journalists
if you hear about the problem a problem
you want to find out if it's true or not
and in this case we ask people not to
talk but to show not to tell but to show
how how they look at this issue of
self-censorship and in fact only I think
only three hours twelve cartoons
depicted the Prophet Mohammed so there
was no stereotyping no demonizing even
though a lot of focus has been put on
one cartoon of the Prophet with a bump
in his turban that to me in fact is a
depiction of reality but there are
Muslims who commit violence and murder
in the name of the Prophet yeah and not
only was that theory proven but it was
put into action because over 200 people
were subsequently killed throughout the
world
after they found out about these
cartoons but before we get to the
aftermath yeah your moat when you
decided to do this and you'd done some
controversial stuff before that we'll
talk about
you know reporting the Soviet unit and
that kind of stuff but when you had
decided to do this did you have any
inkling that anything like this could
possibly happen
no and anyone anyone who today says well
you should have known I think it's it's
a rationalization after the fact there
was a lot of coincidences and in fact
cartoons of the Prophet Muhammad had
been published before without this kind
of reaction it just happened so that a
coincidence of different factors and
domestic political situation in
different Muslim countries exploited
those cartoons to promote their own into
and and agenda and it all exploded yeah
and he probably had a little to do with
just that it was sort of the beginnings
of social media so things could travel
around there the world great Airport and
whatever forces are if this has been
today I I can't imagine I mean we didn't
have Facebook we didn't have Twitter
yeah back in 2005 or just the beginning
yeah today it would have been even worse
yeah okay so you publish it now there's
the reaction there's some violence what
was it like for you at that time and did
the the magazine do anything to help you
protect you were they taking your side
you were the editor so you were pretty
high up yeah I mean oh well I mean the
whole newspaper stood behind me and but
but it took a while I mean the cartoons
were published in September and the
violence only erupted at the end of
January beginning February the following
year so so you had to build up this also
says you a little bit about the fact
that this was no coincidence yeah people
had to you know plan to promote it
wasn't spontaneous just happening right
after the publication yeah do you have
any evidence
yeah I mean yes there are researchers
who have been traveling and talking to
people in different parts of the world
where demonstrations happened and it's
very clear that the government of Egypt
was in the driver's seat in the
beginning the Fatah movement on the West
Bank in the Palestinian territories were
also behind this because they were in an
election of against Hamas the Islamist
you know movement there and they wanted
to be the real protector of Muslims
interests same in in Pakistan same in
Qatar and Saudi Arabia yes absolutely
this was this was not a spontaneous
uprising yeah and usually I say you know
never have so many people reacted so
violently to something that so few
people in fact have seen yeah of course
very few people had seen the cartoons
and and
the the man behind the attack on the
Danish Embassy in Tehran in Iran Danish
journalist found him several months
later and talked to him and when he
showed him the cartoon of the Prophet
with a bump in his turban
he didn't his angry reaction was not
against the bomb but he said why does
the Prophet look like a sick and not
like an Arab huh Wow so that tells you
about right there you make two
interesting
location points because saying that
Fatah which was really the secular
counterpart to Hamas so they were using
it as as you said we're protecting Islam
so you had the secularists actually
fanning the flames and you was exact
Euler and the same thing in Egypt where
Mubarak was the secular leader and he
was up against the Muslim Brotherhood
who had been allowed to run an addiction
for the first time in many years in the
fall of 2005 yeah you know I've never
thought of it in such interesting terms
like that but in a weird way then the
secularists sometimes are more dangerous
than the actual Islamists because
they're playing both sides right were
you shocked that that's how I turned and
I didn't know at the time it took me you
know as some studying to figure out what
actually had happened and you know it
was very surreal I mean you know sitting
in Copenhagen in the beginning of
February 2006 and looking watching TV
and Danish embassies in flames in Beirut
and Damascus I couldn't make the
connection in my mind yeah how come that
people can go crazy like this several
thousand kilometers away to something
that had been published in a Danish
newspaper three four months before it
seems surreal I mean I would say you
know back then I didn't I didn't
understand the gravity of it all it took
me several years and it was only I would
say in January 2015 when my friends and
colleagues achar liam doe in paris were
killed
I finally understood that I will have
probably to live with security problem
for the rest of my life
I somehow illusion myself created an
illusion that somehow it may go away
yeah but it's it won't and these people
they do have a long memory
you know it's I I don't find it very
dramatic myself but I just I just know
that I somehow would have to manage this
situation yeah so what was the reaction
like not so your your newspaper defended
you but what about the other
publications within the country I mean
we're people saying man he just created
a huge problem for us or he actually
defending free speech at the time not
everybody I mean the country was divided
and he was really something new for
Denmark a small peaceful country we were
we we had never experienced anything
like that and the Prime Minister said it
was the worst foreign policy crisis in
Denmark since World War two no back then
I mean I was the object of a lot of
criticism and anger and I was labeled a
fascist Nazi islamaphobe and so on and
so forth so but but today it's it's
different I would say I'm less of a
controversial figure today in Denmark
than I was in 2006 because people have
finally understood that this was not an
empty provocation just to stir up things
is very difficult when you look around
the world and see what is happening that
this was just an invention of my sick
imagination I mean the problem is real
and we have somehow to face it and I
also had the time to write you know
three books in fact now about this issue
one of them published in in English
about the whole thing and free speech
and I think people understand that I'm
I'm not a warmonger and I'm not out to
get Muslims but I think I think Islam
and Muslims have to accept the same kind
of treatment as everybody else in our
society and in that sense usually I make
you know a little bit of a joke but
still it's serious when I say that the
publication those cartoons was in fact
an integration project in the sense that
we were integrating Muslims in Denmark
into a tradition of religious satire and
that by we were saying to Muslims we do
not expect more of you we do not expect
less of you but we expect of you exactly
the same as we do of every other group
and individual in Denmark and there in
lies an act of recognition we say that
you're not foreigners you're not
outsiders you are part of society Yeah
right
we've welcomed you to our society but
you have to be part of our society not a
separate part do you think I never had
so you have to play by the same rules
free speech we do have free speech and
it applies the right to criticise and
ridicule religion yeah just to probably
get rid of some of your naysayers real
quick you clearly do I know this is the
truth but I just want you to say it so
that people won't selectively anything
anything you do make the distinction
between the ideas of Islam and and
Muslim people correct yes you fully
understand that difference at all yes
yes I think I think any idea needs to be
criticized and open for debate and
scrutiny but you shouldn't you shouldn't
attack or demonize individuals and
and people yeah I feel silly sort of
having to ask you that but I know just
for the nature I don't I don't have
Muslims for breakfast yeah and and in
fact some of the people who supported me
back in 2006
now criticize me because I have
supported the right of radical Imams in
Denmark just to speak out and defend
Sharia law and discrimination of women
as long as they do not do it in practice
so we have this separation of words and
deeds I think people should have a right
to say whatever they want as long as
they do not incite criminal activity and
violence and so I have an in fact
defended the the radical Imams who would
have liked to see me I guess in a
different place right so that right now
and that's what having principles when
it's hard to is all about yes so you are
the very person who published these
cartoons now defending these people's
abilities to do things that are very
against the West very against your own
personal beliefs is there some line
there or is it only violence because I'm
with you on that that to me it's the
call to violence that then changes what
free speech is but in a case where there
are Imams that we know that are in
Denmark and Sweden in some of these
other countries that are literally
calling for the overthrow of the
government for Sharia law to be
implemented horrible things about women
and gay people and all those things now
they're playing that line very closely
to you but as long as they do not incite
violence I think this should have a
right to say whatever they want and in
fact I believe this not only as a matter
of principle but also as a matter of
practical reality you and I fight these
people and their ideas in the best way
in or through bans and criminalization
but through an open and free debate
where we challenge them in the public
space I have never seen people change
their beliefs just because they were
criminalized right just cause of a ban
or a poacher who drive them into the
underground and
and it makes them sexy in a way when
they are you know not allowed to air all
their [ __ ] in public so III believe
it's the most effective way to to to
fight them I believe that that that you
should never criminalize words just
because of their content only because of
you know what they called for that is
inciting to violence apart from that I
I'm in favor of a very narrowly defined
libel law and I'm also in favor of the
protection of rights of privacy and I
believe that privacy and free speech in
some instances are two sides of the same
coin because if you know that the
government if we if you know that the
government is surveilling you at home
you will speak less freely and that is
an invasion of your of your privacy yeah
what would you say to the people because
this is the argument that I heard just
in the last couple weeks when I was
defending the right of Richard Spencer
to speak his stuff and not get punched
as I said on Twitter I have family
members on both sides of my family who
died in the Holocaust I grew up knowing
Holocaust survivors it's not something
that I take lightly but I but I have to
defend free speech when it's the
uncomfortable speech people of course
you're saying I was a Nazi and a white
supremacist and all of this nonsense but
what a few people said this is different
that if these people won't play by the
rules of decency in society then we
can't treat them with the same thing now
I don't agree with that but what do you
think is a good argument against that oh
I think I think we we did very well
during the Cold War in in Denmark not
banning communism we didn't even ban
Nazism though we were occupied by the
Nazis for five years during the Second
World War
it's it's it's I mean which as Spencer
enjoys the same civil liberties and
rights as you and me you cannot make a
distinction if you go down that road
it just takes a new political majority
you know with people lively suspense and
power he and he can use the same
principles against you and me Rand
against Muslims or blacks or other
minorities so so so it's it's very
important to defend these principles for
your enemies because it got to take
you're just an election away from a
possible Ottoman majority that can use
exactly the same kind of ireland's
against you that you are defending when
it's used against your enemies so I
think this is what what democracy is
about what what a free and liberal
foundation our society is about that you
you and this is what tolerance in fact
is about tolerance tolerance tolerance
means that you do not pain and you do
not use violence threats and
intimidation against the things that you
hate yeah a lot of people hate the
ideology and the values of Richard
Spencer but we should not use violence
and try to intimidate and threaten him
and pain what he's saying that is the
key notion of Tolerance in a democracy
and unfortunately we have forgotten
about about that today tolerance means
you know yes you may have a right to say
what you want what what you say but I
think you should shut up it's it's
become a tool to silence your opponents
while in fact it means that you had to
write a right to say whatever you want
as long as you do not use violence and
pains right and of course then there's
the slippery slope argument which is
that if you say all right well you can
punch a Nazi or silence a Nazi and then
you come along and defend their free
speech well then why can't they punch
you and why can't they punch me for
having you on my show and the list goes
on or not well yeah and when you when
you open that door you never know when
it stops and and and that's you know
that's very precarious in a young
democracy because sometimes a democracy
wants to defend itself I spent time in
in in Russia after the fall during these
times the Soviet Union after the fall of
the Soviet Union and that transition
in Russia from communism to democracy in
fact got off track because they started
bending the rules in order to defend
democracy against the enemies of
democracy and here you are 20 years
later with a mere portion in in the
Kremlin and and and a lot less space for
the individuals to say and do what they
want
[Music]
[Music]